hello everybody my name is bar tab we
are at Willy come back ooh scary
[Music]
all right this is a long walk home which
is good or bad I don't know if it's good
to walk home by bus you can take me home
but you won't I get it oh my
oh it's keyboard turning oh god its 2004
World of Warcraft up in here okay
was I supposed to go the way the bus was
going because if I was and it could have
dropped me off so I'm assuming well know
if it was that way then it would be the
direction I came from sooner why didn't
I just get off the thing I don't know
which way I'm supposed to go oh this is
disconcerting lick C and put up the
definition for disconcerting yeah that's
what this is
who Peter PETA The Hunger Games
hi um huh oh well that wasn't such a
long walk home my house is right here
and everything is fine wife wife wife
hello mayhaps it's not be mine home why
do those hay bales have buttholes
mysteries we shall never solve some
things mankind was never meant to truly
know I don't like this at all
what is dripping why is there a drip why
is there a drip what is that the tree I
answered my question thank you very much
I don't need your input do not write
comments answering what that was it was
a tree we solved it
Peter Peter your mom's calling you Peter
you better go you mom wants you this my
home are you my mommy
what's dripping is it the piss from my
pants even something's dripping or
something's real squishy so III pissed
my pants or I shat my pants and I'm just
stopping my way back home that's why
it's a long walk home because he's gotta
walk with hoped pants that's no good for
anybody
wife no sorry wrong home just some
horrible strange of shaking doorknobs as
I go down the neighbourhood jungle
jungle jungle ah why why wears black
it's a joke why does the key fit in here
Oh God anyone remember that Oh
oh I can't be good sure are a lot of
downed trees around here you'd think
that that bus would have driven through
these parts men like shush keep on
driving let's not let anybody off you're
clearly death death will only come in
these parts unless this is normal
perfectly fine what's tripping why am i
dripping mommy mommy
he's bleeding profusely out of his anus
ah don't talk about that talk about why
the the the hay bales of anuses I don't
know anyway let's get back to this
serious let's play sorry I slipped into
2012 me what a time to be alive all
right oh this is my home are you my
mommy and if I seen some dirt oh I fi
yeah that's fine that's okay I'm so
drunk I don't remember what my house
looks like God blasted I was responsible
it took public transport and they I
ain't driving that's fine the Hendersons
don't know how to raise cattle you don't
know what the hell they're doing
oh damn Bessie oh no oh that ain't right
Maddy
right that ain't right at all that ain't
right at all anyway just gonna keep
walking
what is that
[Applause]
put them wherever Zenit was in it
what does that move that what was that
did I waste too much time was I supposed
to keep running did I lose hi Bobby I'm
just gonna do this again I'm just gonna
keep walking
I see nothing I see skies of blue I see
skies of black clouds of black fields of
red and roads of mahogany and I say to
myself what happens if I go this way now
there's a thought and a half I go this
way
must come back bus please must please I
need to I got I got problems
oh oh oh no oh I didn't hear that happen
oh no oh they all they all dead oh oh no
bus driver you all right bussy bussy man
bus man oh no well that's not good
oh well you hate to see okay I'll just
I'll slip by I know all right cool thank
you
yeah I'm not good okay that was
horrifying I hated every part of that
but I loved that I hated it makes sense
cool good glad all right cool good start
good start good start dad in side that
referring to me am i dead inside or is
there dead inside my home that's not a
resolution ooh that's better
all right what do we have I don't hear
anything I'm assuming there's gonna be
sound when I get into the game oh
there's some money in the game oh oh
wait wait a minute how does an online
video get corrupted wait wait wait wait
wait what
oh I'm confused
hello onion who kind of prank is this
move these boxes or I'm calling the
police I don't even have a phone got a
contact mom to move these boxes so I can
leave for the concert tomorrow okay well
that's a little strange but nothing to
worry about I guess I'm okay
no weird ass lamp is this God if I'm
being haunted by a ghost I deserve to
die from a lamp like that
battery low plug-in charger to continue
ahh okay why do I have a separate room
for my kitchen and a bathtub and a
toilet this is unsanitary I'm [ __ ]
where I poop and I boopin where I [ __ ]
and I'm cooking where I poop my [ __ ] in
my bathtub full of jello is a brothel
I'm gonna get pooping my jello oh forget
jello in my poop so install my flush
tank can't have a [ __ ] and did okay cool
alright alright sure sure sure
rechargeable battery what is this for my
camera my laptop works
got a contact mom to take care of this
shitty prank well I got to get back to
this video that's gonna give me a
seizure alright okay send mail do
homework alright not that where's my
porn
[Music]
wait yeah that's fun ha
okay the without weird sure sure sure
yeah sure yeah okay sure
all right sure more good for oh sure
Maura come on girl
hi hey all right have fun
see you around how do I make this test
respond my programming language
shouldn't be using my programming
language that's obsolete no one uses it
right okay okay
anybody here is it getting hotter am i
warming back up
god I hope my bathtub full of jell-o
okay cool am i dead
did I died I died I died I somehow died
freaking not again not again all right
well that was interesting
all right oh I need to trace the tetris
block wait what okay why okay so there's
this copy okay I copied there we go got
it whatever that did why was okay I did
my homework send my mail
okay cool Ricky to my mom I don't know
do I have a like a timer am I supposed
to do something about this what do I do
about my coldness my heat my cold and my
colder am i warm what do I do
go outside cure my heat what's wet the
hell the phrases a week mindset okay
okay sorry I can't answer you I'm busy
busy busy as a bee busy as a bee did my
homework I am done with that easy-peasy
- mom - Karen oh yeah okay I'm in deep
[ __ ] thank you mom
I'm should reply I should hit the sack
you got sack hittin time bad Oh jello
bath ah refreshing good thing I have a
towel right here in my kitchen all right
whoa wait oh hi hey what's up I'm dead
inside
apparently so I'm not gonna comment on
the quality or anything at all I'm
moving on I'm moving on anyway this is
this is whoa was that me what's
happening
what just happened
but don't look at it don't look at what
what did I I didn't look at it and I
still died I don't even know what I was
looking at what am I looking at what is
this game called Lexi and put it on
screen quick somethings let's swear to
God hey looking at it who would never
look at it I'd never do anything so
stupid as I look at it I'm not looking
at anything that could be something I
don't know what I'm doing why am i doing
it I know I'm trying desperately not to
look at it and keep looking at it I'm
looking at this oh my light goes out I
didn't know that was a requirement right
of course that's why I'm dying cuz I'm
in darkness makes so much sense now is
Bryce white okay so this is a
well that's a problem oh good great
anyway
sure is a woolly in this apartment
complex which I'm assuming this is a lot
of ghosts in here whoo okay looking at
it everything's based this whole this
whole country has cranked technology
that's all it is there's a bunch of turn
wheels well a Dean up that ain't that
ain't good ain't good dad ain't good
okay it's fine it's fine
what's the problem there is no problem
why would there be a problem with that
trap door is full of monsters with why
Berlin either just crank the light down
to please Oh
[Music]
you you piece of [ __ ] you all right cool
good you got me a few times but still
you're a bastard
all right so considering those last two
were a par I'm gonna do this one called
the silver screens which is not a
theater creepypasta game it is a game
that is about the horrors of working the
night shift at an empty theater really
flashlight they couldn't have turned the
lights on for me go to the employee room
can I give myself some popcorn first I'm
honky I'm big Hangul I'm big hyung go
local girl missing Olivia Harlow missing
well probably has nothing to do with me
I don't know why that's in the trophy
case
yeah that is a little strange hey read
the note on the counter Oh
note on the counter Sudan welcome to
your new permanent night job if you're
reading this then that means the last
employee has already left the building
so the snow will guide you through your
tasks for the night don't worry you're
not here to clean up so many people
always forget their valuable items each
night your job is to simply collect them
and place them inside the lost-and-found
bin located in this room previous
employees have claimed that the piece of
Peers to be haunted by some sort of
shadow no need to worry you have been
equipped with a flashlight and the
cinema lights have been left on for you
the shadow seems to be able to sneak
around in the dark but can only be seen
in the light if you do not see it just
sit in the dark for a while until it
leaves you alone probably a good idea
not to sit still in the dark for too
long though oh no is it running like a
turd I think this might be running like
a turd collect the loss
okay let me see if I can fix this a
little bit anyway some of these games
just run like they run fine they capture
like a turd oDesk much better oh that's
much better
Oh - much better it's not the best
better but it's better okay
whoa search theater one for lost
property okay so what about this shadow
what's the deal with this shadow thing
why is there a shadow and why are you
acknowledging it as a real shadow
thankfully the doors all open for me
that's nice starlight cinemas Wow well
ain't this some but oh did someone leave
their purse did so Oh their bag my
goodness what careless careless people
oh my there's another one
what careless careless people also they
left all this trash behind I can't
believe that Oh purse well I had it sure
oh yes Oh got it nailed it these silly
silly people leaving all these things
behind good thing I'm here to collect
them got that nabbed uh whoop I don't
know what I got but I got something oh
oh god something don't know what
[Music]
I'm sorry that's fine totally fine
oh wait that's fine it's fine it was
fine I died you died why is her shadow
management take care of the shadow I'm
guessing I was supposed to sit in the
dark why does anybody need to be here at
night collected in the morning why would
I need to collect in the night why would
I need to do the night job why would
anybody need to do that okay good reddit
wow I am good scream whoo
ah that's different that is that is
different that's different
nor is long okay so I'm guessing I
should have turned off my light any lost
property bing-bang-boom got that give me
your loss Bertie
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo mone not as much
lost stuff in y'all my goodness there's
a soccer backpack Spiritist babbity spoo
give me your property poo Rick hi Thank
You Labadie wabbit II here comes the bra
babbity nope
[Music]
nothing nothing
easy easy easy
like it's nothing nothing do it nothing
to it but to do it take the property
please no shadows frickin Frick Frick
Frick Frick Frick Frick
what the Frick Frick Wow spooky all
right okay I'm good though
mm-hmm back to my job nothing to worry
about just a horrible shadow monster
just demon you can't hold any more items
oh well this is redonkulous well this is
redonkulous I can't even run this go
bougie oh this is totally fine
so what's about that missing girl can I
get a slushie can I get literally
anything you are now safe yeah uh-huh
sure am I'm safe you large slushie Lu
you are no longer safe yeah uh-huh
I feel that god I miss going to a movie
theater you know what I mean
okay I don't know where I left off pink
top row all right I mean this is a
shadow what in my face Oh see it a lot
of shadow dick okay thank you
well this is relatively simple all I had
to do is stop and flash him a few times
I searched three for lost property there
we go okay good three done three done
I always immediately in front of me that
is problematic don't laugh little shits
oh I don't wanna listen out for her for
her
am i really back at the beginning oh ah
this is kind of tedious if I got to do
all six screens Oh dis yeah I mean it's
kind of spooky but the spook is worn out
very quickly so I'm assuming that when
it appears also it's probably prudent to
go drop off the stuff each time you grab
it but it's prudent to stop immediately
I'm safe I'm safe to stop and wait turn
off the light and wait I get it why
would I not run away screaming even
reading the note that said shadow person
and then you know followed up
subsequently by it's not real but it's
definitely real and you definitely
shouldn't look at it but not real why
would I stay here I shouldn't stay here
I should go run screaming home run
scream home home scream running is what
I should do dumb okay all the good here
I haven't seen the dude in a while oh
sorry the lady the girl so either it's
bug or she's decided them too tough and
too handsome to mess with and as
therefore gone away forever that it's
the likely situation so I'm gonna go
with that
am i okay am i safe might be safe Oh
I'm in the taint of the shadow okay and
I'm out of the taint of the shadow easy
easy peasy oh there we go all done well
that was only two items I might as well
just go to five then screw it we're
going to five we'll do it five all right
easy easy that shadow knows I'm harmless
I'm just a cutie patootie doing my job
getting lost property I'm a good I'm one
of the good ones
perfect okay I think I got drop-off and
then I go to go to six and then I'm done
and then I go home good almost can't
move it wouldn't want that and I'm safe
easy pazoozas
Hazuki Oh Hazuki would be so good right
now it's a pizza cookie ah shut up whoa
what the what the hell oh my god go away
creepy see that was creepy the phone
buzzing is creepy this game needs a few
more creepy things but I did sup pizza
cookie with a scoop of ice cream on it
that's that's divine it's at BJ's
brewery oh there we go I'm all done and
somehow this will cure the curse of the
shadow person at the same time I found
the last Horcrux all better now I am
safe um done I win
oh no I don't know oh god that was it
okay so the game is not bad the premise
is nice I do like the idea of being at a
place in the middle of the night but the
mechanic of kind of mindless items is
tedious at best and the mechanic of the
shadow person is it's not like a
lingering threat it's just like a red
light green light which is like not a
bad mechanic it just could use some
refinement but the concepts nice I like
it a night shift at a job you know
there's a lot of games there like that
you Freddy but there's there's things
that you can do to expand it but not bad
not bad I'm not saying it's bad in any
way shape or form
James Bevan alright so that was the
Reese care games technically for what I
count those other two is half games so
those for scary games just for you extra
value you didn't even need to pay for it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see more scary
games they're linked in the description
it's a playlist with hundreds of videos
oh my god so many videos check it out
links down there and suggested videos
obviously over there thanks again and a
sawhorse I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]